I think there's going to be a very
important conference
and I'll get to that toward the middle
but I have a few things to report and
want to thank you all for being here and
I have to say I think with social
distancing that the media has been much
nicer I don't know what it is all these
empty please
in-between chairs you probably shouldn't
have anybody sitting behind you either
you know I should probably go back but I
love it it's so much nicer but I
shouldn't say that because you'll get me
now thank you all for being here and we
continue our relentless effort to defeat
the Chinese virus before I begin I want
to start by announcing that today we are
bringing home another American citizen
it was a big thing very big Omar hey
Cory is on his way back to the United
States after being imprisoned in Lebanon
since September of 2019 he's battling
late-stage cancer mr. Hikari will now be
able to receive the much needed care and
treatment in the United States we've
been working very hard to get him freed
then he's finally able to have his
entire family at his side so I'm very
grateful to the Lebanese government they
worked with us and we are very proud of
his family they stood by him so strongly
and they are thrilled the United States
has no higher priority than the safety
and well-being of our citizens we've
gotten a tremendous number of hostages
out as you know I think we're 42 and oh
and Robert O'Brien as you know was chief
negotiator for a large part of it
in fact did so well that now we have him
in a different position so I want to
thank and congratulate Robert and his
team and I want to let everyone know
that recovering Americans held captive
and imprisoned abroad continues to be a
top priority for my administration we
have one young gentleman Austin Tice and
we're working very hard with Syria to
get him out we hope the Syrian
government
we'll do that we are counting on them to
do that we've written a letter just
recently but he's been there for a long
time and was captured long ago Austin
Tice his mother's probably watching and
she's a great lady and we're doing the
best we can
so Syria please work with us and we
would appreciate your letting them out
of you think about what we've done we've
gotten rid of the Isis Caliphate Syria
we've done a lot for Syria we have to
see if they're going to do this so it
would be very much appreciated if they
would let Austin Tice out immediately
as you know my administration is working
every day to protect American people and
the American economy from the virus
yesterday I signed into law a critical
support for American workers families
and small businesses big thing we're
providing sick leave and family medical
leave to those affected by the virus and
more health is on the way as we speak
our entire team headed by secretary
minuchin is on the hill we're working
with Democrats and Republicans and
there's a lot of goodwill going on this
was something that happened that was
some people would say an act of God I
don't view it as an act of God I would
view it as as something that just
surprised the whole world and if people
would have known about it it could have
stopped been stopped in place it could
have been stopped right where it came
from China if we would have known about
it if they would have known about it
but now the whole world almost is
inflicted with this horrible with this
horrible virus and it's too bad it's too
bad because we never had an economy as
good as the economy we had just a few
weeks ago but we'll be back and I
actually think we'll be back stronger
than ever before because we learned a
lot
during the spirit of time I also just
invoked the defense production act to
help facilitate distribution of
essential supplies if necessary we're
working with Congress to provide major
additional relief to the workers small
businesses and the hardest hit
industries we want to make sure that
everybody is able to continue on so that
when we recover all of these companies
and these great businesses both very
very small and very very large they're
not gonna be broken up and you'd have to
put them back together that would take a
long time because we really believe in I
believe in the V curve I believe it's
gonna go when this is when this is
defeated this hidden scourge is defeated
I think we're gonna go up very rapidly
our economy and get back to where it was
and beyond today I want to share with
you exciting progress that the FDA is
making with the private sector as we
slash red tape like nobody has ever done
it before somebody was on yesterday or
one of the networks and said that
there's never been a president even
close that's been able to do what I've
done in slashing all of the red tape and
everything to get very important things
to the market medical so we slash red
tape to develop vaccines and therapies
as fast as it can possibly be done long
before anybody else was even thinking
about doing this and as you know earlier
this week we began the first clinical
trial of a vaccine candidate for the
virus and that was launched in record
time it was just a few weeks and that
would have taken years to do not so long
ago as we race to develop a vaccine
we're also pursuing antiviral therapies
and that's what really we're going to be
talking to you about today that's the
purpose of being up here today and to me
that's even more important that you
vaccine by its nature you have to have
long tests because you have to make sure
what goes into somebody's body is not
going to do destruct
do bad things so you need long tests and
they're doing great with the vaccines
but there's still a long process but the
therapies are something we can move on
much faster potentially and the
treatments that we'll be able to reduce
the severity or duration of the symptoms
to make people better essentially with
looking at things to make people better
or at the very earliest stages they
wouldn't even know they had it and
that's where I believe it's going to
work even the best the FDA Commissioner
Steven on who's with us is fantastic and
he's been working 24 hours a day he's
been he's worked like probably as hard
or harder than anybody in this in the
group other than maybe Mike Pence or me
and what the FDA is doing is incredible
they've done things in times that were
not even thinkable and I've directed the
FDA to eliminate outdated rules and
bureaucracy so this work can proceed
rapidly quickly and I mean fast and we
have to remove every barrier there were
a lot of barriers that were unnecessary
and they've done that to get the rapid
deployment of safe effective treatments
and we think we have some good answers
we'll find out very very soon clinical
trials are already underway for many new
therapies and we're working on scaling
these to allow many more Americans to
access different drugs that have shown
really good promise we vet on really
good promise we will do so in a way that
lets us continue to collect good data to
know which medicines are safe and which
medicines are working the best we have a
couple that we're
we're in really good shape on and that's
for immediate delivery immediate like as
fast as we can get it
the FDA has also approved compassionate
use for a significant number of patients
you know what that means we're also
reviewing drugs that are approved abroad
or drugs approved here for other uses
and you know one of the things that I'm
most proud of that I got was right to
try that's where somebody who's ill
somebody who's very sick terminally ill
usually in past administrations we
signed us a year and a half ago you
wouldn't be able to even think about
getting any of the drugs that may be
showing great promise now and they've
been trying for many decades to get this
approved and it sounds simple but it's
not because there's liability involved
and lots of other things and I was able
to get it approved working with Congress
right to try this is beyond right to try
what we're talking about today is beyond
right to try right to try a spin by the
way tremendous success people are living
now that had no chance of living where
we take treatments that would have
things that that would have to go
through years of a process and if
somebody was terminally ill and I would
say why wouldn't they be able to try
this they'd go to Asia they go to Europe
they'd go all over the world to try and
find something or some people have they
had no money we go home to die they go
home to die they had no hope right to
try has been an incredible success but
this is beyond right to try if treatment
is known to be safe in Europe Japan or
other nations are effective against the
virus will use that information to
protect the health and safety of
American people nothing will stand in
our way as we pursue any avenue to find
what best works against this horrible
virus now a drug called chloroquine
and some people would add to it hydroxy
hydroxychloroquine so chloroquine or
hydroxychloroquine now this is a common
malaria drug it's also a drug used for
strong arthritis somebody has pretty
serious arthritis also uses this in a
somewhat different form but it is known
as a malaria drug and it's been around
for a long time and it's very powerful
but the nice part is it's been around
for a long time so we know that if it if
if things don't go as planned it's not
going to kill anybody when you go with a
brand new drug you don't know that
that's gonna happen you have to see and
you have to go long tests but this has
been used in different forms very
powerful drug in different forms and
it's shown very encouraging very very
encouraging early results and we're
going to be able to make that drug
available almost immediately and that's
where the FDA has been so great they
they've gone through the approval
process it's been approved and they did
it they took it down from many many
months to immediate so we're gonna be
able to make that drug available by
prescription or States I spoke with
Governor Cuomo about it at great length
last night and he wants to be right on
on the he wants to be first on the line
and so I think that's a tremendous is
tremendous promise
based on the results and other tests
this tremendous promise and normally the
FDA would take a long time to approve
something like that and it's it was
approved very very quickly and it's now
approved by prescription individual
states will handle it they can handle it
and doctors will handle it
and I think it's gonna be I think it's
gonna be great
then we're quickly studying this drug
and while we're continuing to study it
but the studying is going to be also
done in as it's given out to large
groups of people perhaps in New York and
other places will study if they're there
are promising therapies produced by
Gilead and that's where MD sir voir room
d'Ivoire and that's a drug used for
other purposes that's been out and said
very good results for other purposes but
it seems to have a very good result
having to do with this virus and that
drug also has been approved or very
close to approved in that case by the
FDA and I can't tell you how much we
appreciate what the FDA these people are
incredible Patriots and the job that
Stephen Han is doing dr. Han was one of
the most respected doctors in the
country by the way well we took him I
said you sure you want to do this now we
didn't know that this was going to be in
the playlist what happened here but he
really has stepped up to the plate
wherever you are words a [ __ ] is here
but I'm not supposed to do that getting
a lot of trouble if I did but he's been
fantastic and I thank you doctor he's
gonna speak right after I'm finished so
Regeneron again and is some is a company
that's done fantastically well as I
understand with Ebola and some other
things great company and they're looking
at some very promising events also so
you have rim desks of war and you have
cleric wind and hydro hydroxychloroquine
so those are two that are out now
essentially approved for prescribe use
and I think it's going to be very
exciting I think it could be
a game changer and maybe not and maybe
not but I think it could be based on
what I see it could be a game changer
very powerful they're very powerful
so I want every American to know that
we're doing everything we can and these
actions are important next steps I mean
for the FDA to act the way they acted
with this kind of speed is an incredible
thing normally they'd say well we can
have it by next year or we could have it
by in two years from now you understand
this is the way normally it's like years
and years and years they had it
immediately based on the fact that it's
been used for other things totally
unrelated things we believe these
therapeutics and others under evaluation
right now will be able to provide relief
to many Americans we really hope that's
going to be this could be a tremendous
breakthrough tremendous breakthrough and
we will work toward a much needed to
vaccine in the future as I said and what
we're doing with the FDA is so exciting
in so many other fields so many things
are happening it's a very exciting time
for for medicine and we appreciate that
the American public has pulled together
they're really staying home and I think
there's tremendous spirit in this
country right now it's spirit like a lot
of people have not seen people have not
seen anything like it
for a long time and that means
democrat-republican they're pulling
together I hope everything's going good
in the hill maybe I shouldn't say this
until I check out what's going on
because you never know but but I think
there's a great spirit where the
Democrats the Republicans and everybody
else they're getting together and
they're trying to get things done but
most importantly the American public has
been incredible we took the best economy
we've ever had and we said stop you
can't work you have to stay home you
know there's never been a case like this
normally you pay a lot of money to get
things going here's a case where we're
paying a lot of money to stop things
because we don't want people to
be together so that this virus doesn't
continue onward so there's never been
anything like this in history there's
never been a nobody's ever seen anything
like this but we're doing the right
thing we have to get rid of in our big
war is not a it's not a financial war
it's a war and it's a medical war we
have to win this war it's very important
with that I'd like to just introduce dr.
Stephen Hahn and he again I'd like to
send back with Stephen our thanks to all
of the people working in the FDA who are
fantastic talented people we appreciate
it very much everything you've done
especially the speed that you got these
two elements these two very important
drugs passed thank you very much thank
you mr. president I want to thank you
for your leadership during this corona
virus outbreak and thank you for the
kind words about the FDA staff we have
10,000 scientists doctors and others and
more than that working around the clock
to aid the American people in this fight
against the corona virus and those words
are very much appreciated sir thank you
so um before the president nominated me
and I was confirmed as commissioner from
drugs I was a cancer doctor and I've sat
across from countless number of patients
and had to talk to them about their
diagnosis and their treatment and one
thing that was really important is to
provide hope I have great hope for how
we're going to come out of this
situation what's also important is not
to provide false hope but to provide
hope and as a doctor that's the way I
come to this I'm speaking now to the
American people as commissioner of food
and drugs but that part of me has not
left just look at the way the American
people have responded to our calls for
mitigation
for social distancing American people
have great resiliency and I'm so
incredibly proud of how the American
people have responded as the president
mentioned he asked us to be aggressive
to break down barriers to innovation and
to accelerate the development of
life-saving treatments and we're doing
that at the FDA the FDA is committed to
continuing to provide regulatory
flexibility
guidance but let me make one thing clear
FDA's responsibility to the American
people is to ensure that products are
safe and effective and yet we are
continuing to do that our folks and
their tremendous professionals are
working day and night to do this you
just can't even imagine how much they're
working to provide the support for the
American people and I thank them since
early January long before the first
domestic case FDA began working in
collaboration with CDC I also want to
note that we stood up an incident
command group and have been focused on
the corona virus since the very
beginning of this public health
emergency this is in addition and all of
government and all America proach and
I'll describe what I mean by that in
terms of the development of therapeutics
an important part of that work is
expanding the potential therapeutic
options associated with corona virus and
we've learned from our colleagues across
the globe about this but I I want to
focus on one thing I was a cancer
researcher before all this and one thing
I know about this great country of ours
is that we have unbelievable innovators
we have people who every day it's their
job to develop treatments for all sorts
of diseases we are incredibly blessed as
a country to have this and as is true in
any illness these great American
innovators academia private sector they
have engaged us about the best possible
treatment options we are looking at
everything that's coming across our
desks as possible treatment options for
coronavirus and we're extremely
encouraged by the interest and the
promise that we've seen from these great
American innovators now again we need to
look at it we need the data we need the
information to make the absolute best
decisions for American people but I want
to assure you we have over 17,000 people
at FDA who are doing this every day we
need we need to make sure that these the
see of new treatments will get the right
drug to the right patient at the right
dosage at the right time as an example
we may have the right drug but it may
not be in the appropriate dosage form
right now
and that may do more harm than good
those are the things that that's our job
to look at and that's why it's really
important we have these dedicated
professionals looking at these aspects
of therapeutic development at the same
time we're also working through
different mechanisms to actually get
drugs into the hands of providers and
patients the president mentioned this
but one of the mechanisms called
compassionate use let me just tell you
about this if there's an experimental
drug that's potentially available a
doctor could ask for that drug to be
used in a patient we have criteria for
that and very speedy approval for that
the important thing about compassionate
use and that's what the president meant
this is even beyond right to try is that
we get to collect the information about
that because one of the things there's
no promise the American people is we
will collect the data and then make the
absolute right decisions based upon
those data about the safety and efficacy
of the treatments we are working
expeditiously and we are working to make
sure that these products are as safe and
effective as they possibly can be can be
let me tell you about a few things that
we're currently working on and this is a
plan that was developed with many of the
people at this table are infectious
disease experts on the task force in the
short term we're looking at drugs that
are already approved for other
indications so they're already approved
as the president said for other diseases
as an example many Americans have read
studies and heard media reports about
this drug chloroquine which is an
anti-malarial drug it's already approved
as the president said for the treatment
of malaria as well as in arthritis
condition that's a drug that the
president has directed us to take a
closer look at as to whether an expanded
use approach to that could be done to
actually see if that benefits patients
and again we want to do that in the
setting of a clinical trial a large
pragmatic clinical trial to actually
gather that information and answer the
question that needs to be answered and
asked and answered let me give you
another example
there's a cross-agency effort about
something called convalescent plasma
this is a pretty exciting area and again
this is something that we have given
assistance to other countries with as
this crisis has developed so FDA's been
working for some time on this
if you've been exposed to coronavirus
and you're better you don't have the
virus in your blood we could collect the
blood now this is a possible treatment
this is not a proven treatment just want
to emphasize that collect the blood
concentrate that and have the ability
once it's pathogen-free that is virus
free be able to give that to other
patients and the immunoglobulins the
immune response could potentially
provide a benefit to patients it's
another thing that we're looking at over
the next couple weeks we'll have more
information that we're really pushing
hard to try to accelerate that that's in
this sort of more medium short term and
that'll be a bridge to other therapies
that will take us three to six months to
develop and this is a continuous process
there is no beginning and end to each of
this this is you know we're pushing this
through the other great thing about the
great innovators of America some of them
tell us it's taken us years years to
develop therapies they're looking at
pushing that to the months period of
time and we're trying to provide them
the regulatory flexibility but at the
same time the scientific oversight to
make sure that gets done in the best way
possible for the American people the
president mentioned that there is a
vaccine trial currently being performed
it's a phase one trial so it's the
earliest study that gets done we expect
that to take 12 months to get depletion
to actually a time where we could
approve a vaccine but that's these are
all things to bridge to the prevention
part of this with a vaccine it's
exciting work and the president is right
this is record time for the development
of a vaccine and impressive
public-private partnership the FDA's
efforts to facilitate the development of
these products are focused on ensuring
timely access while also meeting the
agency's world respected gold standard
relying on strong data from clinical
trials to determine if an experimental
or an off-the-shelf drug that's used for
something else can safely and
effectively treat patients we want to
assure the American people that FDA is
all hands on deck as the president
mentioned these efforts and continue to
work with interested sponsors to help
expedite the work we remain steadfast in
helping to foster the development of
safe and effective therapies for koba 19
thank you
Thank You mr. president the White House
coronavirus task force met this morning
and on this very first day of springg we
continue to make steady progress toward
president Trump's objective not only to
marshal all the resources of the federal
government every state government every
every local health official but also to
harness the power of the American
private sector and activities over the
last day reflect all of those priorities
yesterday the president spoke with
America's top physicians and nurses and
garnered helpful insights about how we
can best serve those who are serving
Americans that are dealing with the
coronavirus we also had a productive
call with over 5,000 state and local
officials explaining the federal
government's approach and our strong and
seamless partnership with all 50 states
in the territories last night as you
heard the president side the family
first coronavirus response Act which
provides free coronavirus testing paid
sick leave family leave for caregivers
and food assistance for the needy among
a broad range of benefits and today as
the president indicated we expect that
the Senate will begin work on an
economic relief package later today the
president and I will meet again in a
teleconference with the nation's
governors we will meet at the National
Response Coordination Center at FEMA and
outline president Trump's decision to
have FEMA take the lead in our national
coronavirus response our nation's
response through FEMA will be locally
executed state managed and federally
supported on testing we want the
American people to know once again the
testing is available in all 50 states as
is becoming increasingly available
literally every hour of the day because
of the public-private partnership that
the president initiated several weeks
ago with major commercial labs I'm
pleased to receive a report today that
tens of thousands of tests are being
performed every day and with the passage
of last night's legislation
estate and private labs are now required
by law to report all coronavirus testing
directly to the CDC which will give the
American public and also give our
researchers timely and important
information it's important for every
American to remember that if you don't
have symptoms you don't need to get a
test we want to make sure the testing is
available for people that are
experiencing symptoms or have a genuine
concern about having been exposed to
someone with the coronavirus dr. Burks
will address county level data as well
as the progress we've made on testing
and Americans can expect to see how an
increased number of cases as our new
testing system comes online should not
be a cause of concern she'll explain the
importance of taking into account our
new testing system as new data arrives
over the next several days on supplies a
priority the president has given to our
task force we continue to work with
healthcare providers businesses and
state leadership to identify available
supplies not merely in the federal
stockpile but much more importantly
available across the private sector
we're encouraged to see companies like
Honeywell and 3m that I visited a few
short weeks ago take advantage of the
changes in the law last night that allow
the sale of industrial masks directly to
hospitals those companies have now
greatly increased by the tens of
millions their production of so-called
n95 masks that will give our health care
workers the protection that they need to
minister to those that are dealing with
the symptoms or the disease of
coronavirus I'm following the signing of
last night's bill all of those masks now
have liability protection and the
companies can sell industrial masks to
hospitals it is encouraging as we called
out yesterday to see construction
companies all across America that are as
we speak
checking their supplies and donating
those industrial masks to their local
hospitals and I know I speak on behalf
of the president who spent a lot of time
as a builder when we thank builders
across America for partnering with our
local healthcare officials
on the subject of ventilators we're
working with healthcare providers around
America and and suppliers and I'm we're
encouraged to learn that we've literally
identified tens of thousands of
ventilators that Bing can be converted
to treat patients and we remain
increasingly confident that we will have
the ventilators that we need as the
coronavirus makes its way across America
and as we said before this we're all in
this together
and before I step away and and give the
podium back to the president and to dr.
Burks I want to call every American's
attention again to the president's 15
days to slow the spread you continue to
hear one case after another one city
after another where people are putting
into practice the principles that the
president outlined this Monday and make
no mistake about it that while for the
American people as a whole the risk of
serious illness remains low these
guidelines should be practiced by every
American in every community not only to
lessen the spread of the corona virus
but to protect the most vulnerable among
us and I think Americans with their with
from their hearts are not only
practicing these principles of social
distancing and avoiding social
gatherings of more than 10 people using
drive-throughs at restaurants to protect
their own health and the health of their
family but they're also recognizing that
no American wants to inadvertently
convey the coronavirus to someone for
whom the consequences could be quite
serious at the president's Direction
will continue to marshal all the
resources of government at every level
we'll be reiterating that strong
partnership with America States this
afternoon with America's governor's
pulling all of the private sector energy
together the innovation that you just
heard described I know on this first day
of spring that we'll get through this
and we'll get through this together
thank you mister
thank you very much
thank you Thank You mr. president so I
know you're watching the data carefully
you can see the dramatic increases in
the number of new cases based on our
ability to test additional people and
this will continue over the next two to
three days as we begin to have backlogs
reduced of the testing you all have
heard the antidotes of people waiting
five or six days for their test results
we are moving through all of that as
well as testing individuals I really
want to applaud the frontline healthcare
workers the nurses and the doctors and
the testers that have really prioritized
and the American people who have a
prioritized those with symptoms the
number of tests positive is increasing
that is a dramatically important
signature that everybody is doing their
job those with mild symptoms are staying
home self isolating those with serious
symptoms are coming forward to getting
testing our test positive rates are now
into the ten to eleven percent range
that still means that 90 percent of the
illness is out there even the severe
ones are not covet 19 I know many of you
are looking at the state-level data
still over 50% of the cases come from
three states this is why we continue to
prioritize testing in those states in
addition 50% of the cases come from ten
counties we're a very large country with
very many counties and I just want to
applaud the local and state governments
that are implementing their emergency
operation centers and plans to ensure I
want to also really thank the health
care workers that have been asked to
reduce all elective surgeries medical
and dental visits this will dramatically
increase the number of ventilators that
are available in hospitals but also in
ambulatory surgical centers that can be
converted and utilized and also the to
the construction industry we are deeply
grateful the number as vice president
said the number of individuals have come
forward with their construction mask
their booties their art I've exit on
suits and their masks to contribute them
to the healthcare sector
the President's request to make this
available in that legislation changes
the ability and increases our
availability immediately by than 75 to
90 percent range because the amount of
construction use of those elements thank
you thank you very much
Thank You mr. president mr. vice
president huh
today you heard a wonderful announcement
from the FDA and I just want to give a
shout out to Steve dr. Hahn and the
folks at the FTA were about what several
hundred of my commissioned Corps
officers work you're right mr. president
they are tireless they're doing things
that have never been done before
to bring the most most prudent advances
to the American people but I want to
talk about something different briefly
we know many of you are home practicing
the president's guidelines for social
distancing but one thing we should all
consider especially our Millennials in
Gen Z is donating blood as an
anesthesiologist who still practices at
Walter Reed taking care of our wounded
warriors and our soldiers I know donated
blood is an essential part of caring for
patients and one donation can save up to
three lives blood centers are open now
and in need of your donation I want
America to know the blood donation is
safe and blood centers are taking extra
precautions at this time based on new
CDC recommendations including spacing
beds 6 feet apart disinfecting surfaces
between patient's temperature checking
staff and encouraging donors to make
appointments ahead of time so we can
space them out social distancing does
not have to mean social disengagement so
give blood today you'll feel good about
it and you'll be helping your country
and your community during this crisis
and you might even save a life
yeah switching to the the Epis to boost
the economy with the measures for
Congress will you guarantee that the
money the billions the tens of billions
of dollars hundreds of billions of
dollars even that's gonna go but to
these industries will not go to
executive bonuses or to more stock
buybacks well we don't want that in fact
some companies as you know did stock
buybacks and I was never happy with that
it's very hard to tell them not to but I
would tell them not to I would say I
don't like it for that reason some did
and it turned out that they could have
waited a long time it would have been
much better off if they did the
condition of the bill you could say and
none of this money can go I'm making I
mean you know it takes many many people
in this case to tango but as far as I'm
concerned that conditions like that
would be okay with me question for you
and then a question for dr. klahn you
enabled I guess is probably the best way
to put it the defense production act
yesterday beginning pull the trigger on
it no because we hope we're not going to
need that calls on Capitol Hill from the
Democratic leadership pull the trigger
on wait what's the rationale for not
doing first of all governors are
supposed to be doing a lot of this work
and they are doing a lot of this work
federal government's not supposed to be
out there buying vast amounts of items
and then shipping you know we're not a
shipping clerk the governors are
supposed to be as with testing the
governor suppose are supposed to be
doing it will help out and will help out
wherever we can and we can buy in volume
and in some cases great volume with the
masks as an example which were really a
problem we have helped out and they're
right now millions of masks being made
but this is really for the local
governments governors and people within
the state depending on the way they
divided it up and they'll do that and
they're doing a very good job of it
where you have a problem with
ventilators we're working very hard
trying to find nobody in their wildest
dreams would have ever thought that we
need tens of thousands of ventilators
this is something that's very unique to
this to what happened
conditions would you put the defense
production entity into action well if we
were desperately in need of something
and we frankly will know about that very
shortly we want to be ahead of we don't
want to do it as it happens but before
it happens we're going to know a lot
over the next two or three days we'll
know a lot any idea when REM disappear
will be available to the market and are
there any drugs in the pipeline that you
believe could qualify for a treatment I
have data so with respect to the first
question I'm prohibited by law to
disclose confidential commercial
information what I can tell you is we're
working very closely with the company on
this and we'll have additional
information they will relatively soon
yes there are drugs in the pipeline
we're looking at everyone everyone on
this dais gets calls every day as to all
of our people at the FDA about potential
therapeutic options we are looking at
every single one of them we're trying to
find that out this has been going on for
years many years they've been trying to
find Austin Tice he was in Syria as you
know his mother is an incredible woman
and I'm doing it for him but I'm doing
it for his mother his mother's an
incredible woman who is desperate to
find her son and I'm not confirming a
lot but if if he is alive if we would
like very much to get him back quickly
okay and on coronavirus speaking of
shortages of supplies the CDC has put
out guidelines for hospitals that are
dealing with
shortage of mass to use them beyond
their shelf life reuse them instead of
getting new ones and in a worst-case
scenario use a bandana instead of a mask
how is that acceptable at all well I
haven't seen that but I will let Mike
answer that question by suppressing I'm
happy to mr. president I just I can't
emphasize enough the incredible progress
that was made with the passage of the
legislation last night and President had
me go to Minnesota meet with 3m that
manufactures these in 95 mass a few
weeks ago and we learned of their
production at that facility of 35
million mass a month less than 5 million
of those were qualified to be sold to
hospitals so President worked with
Republican and Democrat leadership we've
extended the liability protection so now
that all the industrial masks that are
manufactured as n95 s are now available
to hospitals and we're seeing a dramatic
increase in production
Honeywell alone is repurposing a factory
that was destined for Mexico to produce
another hundred and twenty million mass
per year 3m is increasing output to 420
million masks per year we really we've
put a priority at the president's
direction on making sure those that are
providing health care services to
America have the protection to keep
themselves and their families safe and
with the legislation last night with the
incredible response among these great
private-sector companies and as we
mentioned repeatedly with construction
companies around America heating the
president's call to donate their
industrial mass to hospitals it's
happening all over America we know we'll
meet that need
or at least we start getting them ready
well as I mentioned 3m is increasing
their output 420 million a year at
production and January they make 35
million per month at that facility and
we're we're prioritizing the
distribution of those but the other
thing and we'll emphasize this with
governor's this afternoon is we're
working with governor's to make sure
that the healthcare providers the
hospitals and the clinics in their state
are placing orders now that this
tremendous increase in supply
particularly with industrial mass is now
available we're going to make sure they
understand that the supply has greatly
expanded thanks to a bipartisan
legislation and the accomplishment the
president and the response by these
companies is making more mass available
and we're gonna make sure healthcare
providers are purchasing those and the
federal government will also make sure
that our stockpile is properly reflects
those increases as well they're
available now the 3m facility that I was
at told me in that in January they went
to full production on 35 million masks
the legislative change means that all 35
million of those that started to be
produced at full capacity in January can
now be sold to hospitals that's the
distinction here it's a very important
change and it's part of the way the
president has been engaging the private
sector pushing the kind of regulatory
reform and the kind of liability reform
that has greatly expanded the
availability of mass so they're in the
marketplace now we're gonna make it
clear to governor's as we made it clear
to healthcare providers in conference
calls yesterday that those resources are
now there we've vastly increased the
supply of medical mass and we're going
to continue to put a priority on making
sure that we're calling on industry at
every level calling on major suppliers
that the president met with this week to
make sure that those personal protective
equipment are there and to do with the
liability
the company that had a big problem with
liability and much of it had to do with
the liability to the company thank you -
for you in one for dr. Han the American
Hospital Association just told NBC News
that they need a hundred billion dollars
in order to address shortages in
equipment and other infrastructure there
you just signed two legislative packages
they say it didn't directly give money
to address this issue why not and will
you commit to me looking at that issue
directly with them and that's a separate
issue but we're looking at that issue
very directly we're working with
Democrats and Republicans or that we're
looking at that very specifically you
bottom-line people when can Americans
expect their lives to go back to normal
will that not happen until there's a
vaccine I hope person will see this is
uncharted territory as you know we think
we have ideas it doesn't help to say
what the ideas I would hope very soon
we're we've pulled together as a nation
people are for the most part doing what
they're supposed to be doing the social
distancing is very interesting a whole
new term that's become a hot it's become
somewhat of a hot term but people are
listening and they're and they're really
doing a great job this country is an
amazing country I think you're up to 141
different countries right now so it's
very uncharted territory could have
could have been stopped could have been
stopped pretty easily if we had known if
everybody had known about it a number of
months before people started reading
about it excuse me before we started
reading about we could have it could
have been stopped in its tracks
unfortunately they didn't decide to make
it public but the whole world is
suffering because of it
did have a sense that this was a
pandemic that was coming so why was the
United States not prepared with more
testing we were the only thing we
weren't prepared for was the the media
the media has not treated it fairly I'll
tell you how prepared I was I called for
a ban from people coming in from China
long before anybody thought it was in
fact it was your network I believe they
called me a racist because I did that it
was many of the people in the room they
called me racist and other words because
I did that because I went so early so
when you say we weren't prepared had I
left these tens of thousands of people
come in from China a day we would have
had something right now that would have
been you wouldn't have even recognized
it compared to where we are how many
people have passed away how many people
have died as of this moment you could
multiply that by a factor of many many
many so when you say that I wasn't
prepared I was the first one to do the
ban now other countries are following
what I did but the media doesn't
acknowledge that they know it's true
they know it's true but they don't want
to write about it for other personal
protective gloves other equipment
governors are saying they don't have
access to respirators and they're
terrified what is your suppose to get it
the states is supposed to get it but
we're helping the states look for years
they bought them and now all of a sudden
they're coming to the federal government
we're working with the states we're
working with the governor's we're
working with everybody the relationships
are great one of the things that
happened this morning I spoke with Micky
Arison of Carnival Cruise Lines
and he's going to make ships available
so in addition to the big medical ships
that you have coming if we should need
ships with lots of rooms
they'll be docked at New York and Los
Angeles and San Francisco different
places so I want to thank Mickey ears
and that's Carnival Cruise Lines
about invoking the defense production
I've done it yeah if we find that we
need something that we will do that and
you don't know what we've done you don't
know whether or not we've ordered you
don't know if we've invoked it you don't
know what's been ordered what's not
there I can only tell you I can only
tell you that as an example masks nobody
ever heard of the number of mass that's
been ordered they're being made now and
many are available now but people I
think in the media probably don't know
that could you explain the gap and for
the American people and what you're
saying here today about there being tens
of thousands of tests available about
how they're being a huge amount of masks
available and what we're seeing on the
ground which is really the opposite of
that people are people are saying that
they can't get tested even when they
have symptoms people are saying that
they doctors are telling us they don't
have access to vital equipment can you
explain that that gap well I can't I
cannot explain a gap I'm hearing very
good things on the ground and we're
dealing with love they had a ramp up
they had an obsolete system and they had
a system simultaneously that was not
meant for this it wasn't meant for this
nobody knew there'd be a pandemic or an
epidemic of this proportion nobody's
ever seen anything like this before I
can tell you that what we're doing is
we're working with local governments
with states governors even mayors on
getting them to be able to get what they
need and the system is starting to work
out very well but we had a breaker
system like breaking an egg because the
system we had was obsolete and didn't
work and that was a system we inherited
and now we have something that's really
been very good and certainly going to be
great for the future too yeah
building among professional Republicans
and then your supporters about a
corporate bailout in particular senator
my bronze say it's been hearken back to
2008 where we're picking winners and
losers and the end kid that his
colleagues may not be comfortable with
that will you save it well we don't want
to pick winners and losers we want
everybody to benefit we want I think
more than anything else the workers to
benefit and sometimes for the worker to
benefit you have to go through the
company because they have thousands of
workers and if the company goes out of
business no fault of their own those
workers aren't going to be able to
receive a check so we're look our
ultimate goal or the people our ultimate
goal of the great people of this country
and we will have things worked out I
think that are going to be very well
it's a very complex formula you
understand that very complex but it's
working out I think it's going to be
very well I think we're gonna have
pretty uniform support for it please
Department is gonna put out an advisory
telling America's not to travel overseas
at all are you putting in an overseas
travel but we're speaking with the State
Department later I can't say right now
because I haven't had the meeting yet
about today's announcement if I hear
whose background thank you so much I
wanted to ask out rent rent severe I
don't pronounce that correctly
can you tell say it currently approved
for use on the virus so REM des aveer
and it's a drug made by Gilead that's
been in the press it is currently in
clinical trials here and around the
world we have also made it available by
that approach that I told you called
compassionate use where a doctor could
ask the FDA for that and the really
positive thing about that that gives it
rapidly to a doctor and a patient but it
allows us to collect the data because
what we really need to do is understand
what the data and science are in order
to make the appropriate decision about
safety and effectiveness so how do you
make sure that it is safe and I mean is
there any concern at all that it will be
safe considering that it's not going
through the normal process and and could
potentially cause negative effects dr.
pouchy
earlier talked about we do not want to
put out anything that can cause a
negative effects is there any concern
about those kind of things with rip this
drugs yeah thank you for that question
because I just want to be clear about
this
Ramez aveer is going through the normal
process we are using our internal
processes at fda to set up with the
company the protocols to actually
collect the data and you're right we
need to actually know about the safety
and the effectiveness and that's done
through the clinical trial process so
it's those data that are going to inform
the decisions that are ultimately made
about safety and efficacy this is a an
unprecedented situation this is a really
significant time and one thing that with
the president's leadership fda has done
is said okay how do we approach these
extraordinary times with extraordinary
measures knowing that we have a sacred
trust with the American people about
safety and efficacy but still at the
same time enable these treatments to get
into patients and that's what we're
doing the doctors how likely is it that
the 15 day guidance that you would have
proved will be extended I can only go
before Tuesday and we'll have to see
we'll have indications later on dr.
Burks indicated that there are three
states and ten counties if I got that
right where 50% of the cases are focused
should those areas be doing more
measures such as shelter-in-place I
think they actually are doing a lot I
mean they I know New York is working
very diligently been very strong
I assume San Francisco's one of the
areas in Los Angeles and the state of
Washington obviously that's one that has
to be up there they're all working very
hard to to quarantine or words just
about the equivalent of quarantine plan
serves more government workers
are you moving for the government as
well to start doing more teleworking we
are and we're doing we're using the
medical term of telemedicine and it's
been incredibly busy and really you know
what people don't have to everybody some
people can't do it anyway they can't get
up they can't see a doctor but we're
using this and it's been telehealth
different names and I will tell you that
it's been really successful it's helped
a lot of people out where they don't
have to and they can't and even from a
safety reason if they are positive they
are if they are feeling poorly they
can't do it or we don't want them
transmitting anything to anybody else on
China they reported for the first time
since the outbreak no new cases over a
24-hour period do you have any reason to
disbelieve them and second to that the
National Security Council yesterday put
out a tweet very critical of the Chinese
government saying the Chinese Communist
Party suppressed initial reports and the
Chinese virus and punished doctors and
journalists causing Chinese and
international experts to miss critical
opportunities to prevent a global
pandemic could you explain it would have
much better if we had known about this a
number of months earlier it could have
been contained to that one area in China
where it started and certainly the world
is paying a big price for what they did
and the world is paying a very big price
but not for not letting them come out
everybody knows that we all know that as
far as as far as believing what they're
putting out now I hope it's true who
knows but I hope it's true
very quickly a question for you and then
also for the doctor if possible
you've been talking about China quite a
bit and you've been talking about the
Chinese virus how if you have heard
about this on day one and had more
information possibly you could have
stopped every difference are you
thinking about any types of
repercussions for China and are you also
rethinking sort of the supply lines for
our manufacturing industry I don't want
to comment on that right now yeah I have
a question for you and also question for
dr. Burks at you American workers across
the country are losing their jobs an
unprecedented rate and your former
economist said we could see some of the
worst job numbers ever is the government
prepared to see this spike in
unemployment no worst case scenario you
would have terrible job numbers if we
can get this thing wrapped up and
finished earlier things will go very
nicely and one of the things they're
working as you know one of the elements
that is being worked on very much so in
the hill is to keep the jobs going so
that when we do get rid of the virus
we're going to be able to just really I
think go like a rocket I think the
economy is going to be fantastic now
when he said that he was using that as
the ultimate bad outcome I don't think
anybody believes so it's going to happen
you know that members of Congress are
now being tested positive for members of
Congress are not being tested positive
for echovirus and you have almost two
dozen or self-quarantine do you have any
guidance for Congress should they I know
all of them and I don't know if they're
sitting like you people are sitting
you're actually sitting too close
you should really we should probably get
rid of about another 75 80 percent of
you I'll have just two or three that I
like in this room I think that's a great
way of doing it we just we get a new way
of doing it but you're actually much too
close Yuki you should leave immediately
but but look look I know all of them
they tested positive hopefully they're
all going to get better and it's one of
those things it's Congress where they
tested positive they're in quarantine
and I know Lindsey and many others are
they they didn't test it but until they
got the result they put themselves in
quarantine a number of people in
Congress right now are in quarantine
they don't know the results when they
get the result they'll leave this stay
there and get better because people get
better I mean most people are getting
better most by far the people are you
get better doesn't mean it's not a tough
one it is a tough one but now when they
many people in Congress have felt not
perfect or they met somebody that wasn't
perfect it turned out to be positive and
they've put themselves in quarantine and
I think that I think Congress has
behaved unbelievably well in that regard
on the stimulus sir given what is
happening the economy do you think a
trillion-dollar stimulus is enough well
know about that later Oh we'll see what
happens it depends how long so much
depends on what's going on in this room
in terms of the medical if we can stop
it in its tracks the virus it's plenty
if we can't we'll have to go back and
talk do you support the idea of the
government taking an equity stake in
certain companies I do people are coming
people are coming in for money in some
cases no fault of their own but in some
cases where they did certain things over
the course of the years including by
buying back stock you know they bought
back stock and they paid a high price
for it as it turned out but maybe I view
that as a little bit differently than
somebody that didn't then somebody that
bill plants all over the United States
of which there were plenty of them two
airlines are Boeing or what what do you
think we will be helping the airline
industry we will be helping the cruise
ship industry we probably will be
helping the hotel industry will probably
be where jobs are created you don't want
to lose industries like this these are
incredible industries you can't lose
them so we'll be focused on many
industries and I have to say I can't
state it struggling enough we will be
helping small businesses that's where
it's complicated because a lot of small
you know that's the engine of the of the
country we will be helping small
business
laughter mr. Burley to members of
Congress that have tested positive for
rotavirus these will be birds that you
need to pause this one trillion dollar
stimulus package for the economy do you
expect this to slow down the delivery of
checks for American families and are you
considering any new executive action
that could be we're looking at a couple
of things that I could do hopefully
won't need it but we can do was there's
a lot of executive power if we don't
have to use it that would be a good
thing not a bad thing yet please Thank
You mr. president
one for you and potentially as well one
for dr. Berger dr. Adams right now the
economy is essentially ground to a halt
thanks for telling stories of close
travel has slowed down
what's the rich deflation we know that
everybody in the room knows it the
question is how long should those who
are either not working right now or
business owners who have to make
critical decisions how long should they
expect the state of affairs as it stands
at this moment to play out and for for
the doctors behind you be able to tell
you that very I think in the near future
we'll see where we're going you're gonna
see numbers you've seen the graphs
you're gonna see numbers and we'll be
able to let you know I will say that the
American public has been incredible for
the most part not at all cases but for
the most part so you'll be able to see
what's happening over the desk as we say
we had a 15-day period you'll be able to
tell a lot in a week or so not
everything but we'll be able to see over
a period of time and for all the parents
that are home right now this is a
question for dr. burns or dr. Adams who
are caring for their children and are
curious as to when my kids be able to go
back to school what do you think is a
realistic timeline well I think you know
most of all of those decisions are made
at the state and local government level
and each state and local government has
handled it differently
that's why we put out from the president
federal federal presidential guidance to
every single person about what we think
is important for the next two weeks and
as we look at that data
we'll be able to see if it's having an
impact I think you've all seen the
modeling studies those were driven by
the modeling studies showing that you
add these things
together they have a bigger impact than
separately and so those are part of the
decision-making we had a whole group of
modelers in yesterday they're
compositing all the data together to
look at this carefully because everyone
has those same questions of what the
impact will be and what pieces could
essentially be removed and you still
have the same level of impact in
decreasing the spread of the virus the
absolute key to this though is every
single American looking at the president
guidelines and taking it seriously the
acts of selflessness that I am seeing
are so impressive across the board but
if even 10 or 15 percent of the
population decides that what they're
doing today is more important than the
health and welfare of the rest of the
Americans they can spread the virus in a
very strong way because you know the
level of contagion chloroquine or
hydroxychloroquine works or any of the
other things that they're looking at
that are not quite as far out but if
they work your numbers are going to come
down very rapidly so we'll see what
happens but there's a real chance that
they might just so Sunday was taking
photos with supporters in gorging mass
demonstration and just yesterday
presidents from Brazil said that we
should not be surprised if receive him
in the next few days in a crowded subway
in Sao Paulo or in a bus in Rio because
he is the president it should view the
people what do you think about that
what's your message
well he's a friend of mine number one
and number two we had dinner the other
night and everybody said he was positive
and he wasn't positive he tested
negative so that was I I was quite happy
when I heard that but I have no message
for a mother than he's doing a good job
in Brazil
Brazil is very popular Oh God
encouraging my illustration at these
moments I can't tell you about that I
don't know about that I have not heard
that he's doing a very good job Brazil
was very troubled before he got there
and he's the people loved him and
popular I think he's doing a very good
job there are Americans who were
travelling abroad or essentially stopped
unable to come home we spoke to a green
beret ten women hope Americans to wear
her well we spoke to ten American women
who were in Morocco for instance all the
flights have been canceled their hotel
is shutting down they literally have no
place to stay and no way to get home
they are asking you they're asking the
administration the US government for
help what can be done we know about it
we have groups we have a group of young
people in in Peru and we're working on
taking care of that with the military
military evacuated take nonot evacuation
what we're trying to get them out and
you know they got caught they were late
with their flights we gave them a period
of time they didn't make it but we're
looking to get them out with military
probably through the military we have a
group of young young people I think
young men or young people could be women
also with them from Alabama the great
state of Alabama and they're in Peru and
we're working on that right now trying
to get them out it's a large group it's
about 300 well we're gonna work it out
Jeff - president - sort of foreign
policy related questions and your talk
with the g7 leaders earlier this week
did you discuss together ending or
postponing the Olympics yeah we discuss
it as you know Prime Minister Abbey was
on the call and that's a big decision
for him and we don't know what his
decision is but we'd live with this
decision it's a tough situation they've
done an incredible job
Japan has done an incredible job when
building the venue's getting them built
you know you've seen so many Olympic
venues that have been a disaster over
the years where they cost five times
more than they were supposed to they
weren't ready in time Japan has been
just the opposite they built it
beautifully they built it for what it
was supposed to be built for but
he got hit with the same thing that the
rest of the world got hit with
unexpectedly he as he has told us that
he has not made a decision as to what to
do so on foreign policy have you spoken
to the leaders of Saudi Arabia or Russia
and encouraged them to stop this glut of
oil that is detected in the market well
the one thing I will tell you is that
from the standpoint you always get a
little bit torn because you know until
we became the leading producer I was
always for the person driving the car
and filling up the tank of gas and you'd
have gasoline and the prices were if
they were too high I would always raise
hell with OPEC and I was always somebody
that liked saying I never thought I'd
see 22 and 24 and 28 dollars a barrel
but that's what we have and in one way
our consumer is very much helped it's
like it's like a massive tax increase
that's bigger than any tax increase
decreased that you could give you know
we can give all these big tax cuts but
they're paying so little for gasoline
but on the other hand it hurts the great
industry and a very powerful industry so
I spoke with numerous people that have a
lot to do with it and we have a lot of
power over the situation and we're
trying to find some kind of a medium
grant you know it's it's very
devastating to Russia because when you
look I mean the whole economy is based
on that and they have we have the lowest
oil prices in decades so it's very
devastating to Russia I would say it's
very bad for Saudi Arabia but they were
in a fight they were in a fight on price
they were in a fight on output and at
the at the appropriate time I'll get
involved you will the Carnival cruise
ships be used for well Mickey called up
and he said if you need them and we
haven't said yes I'll call Governor
Cuomo I'll I'll call Gavin from Kevin
Newsome governor from California I'll
call a few of the other governors
they're going to bring it up today
because we're meeting through phone
through telephone telephonically as they
say in a little while at FEMA I'm going
over FEMA from here
well you can increase places to stay
let's say places to stay if it works I
mean you know I don't know maybe people
won't wanna but he made the offer was a
very generous offer and he said that he
has some ships that would be ideally
suited for what we're doing and
certainly they have a lot of rooms
they're big and they have a lot of rooms
so we appreciate it from Carnival you're
talking about not needing a test right
now if you're not showing any symptoms
but a lot of leading the test or only
getting tested if you're showing
symptoms but a lot of this well you
should only good we should I didn't have
any symptoms that I got a test but I got
a test because you people were driving
everybody crazy so that's the only
reason I had no symptoms but I had a
test and my doctor told me don't get it
you don't need it everybody said you
don't need it but I had to do it because
the press was going crazy and then after
I got it they said you shouldna garden
it you had no symptoms you know the
whole thing so in other words if you get
it it was no good but that's I'm a
unique case unfortunately but no people
that don't show symptoms and people that
have doctors that say they shouldn't get
it I would rely on that yeah I would
rely on do you consider the Oh a
racist no it's food that originates in
China or it has to no I don't think it's
racist I don't think it's racist at all
on that note major left-wing news media
even in this room have teamed up with
Chinese Communist Party narratives and
they're claiming you are racist for
making these claims about Chinese bars
is it alarming that major media players
just oppose you are consistently siding
with foreign state propaganda Islamic
radicals and Latin gangs and cartels and
they work right here at the White House
with direct access to you and your team
it amazes me when I read the things that
I read it amazes me when I read The Wall
Street Journal which is always so
negative
it amazes me when I read the New York
Times is not even I don't i barely read
it you know we don't distribute it in
the White House anymore in the same
thing with the Washington Post because
you see I know the truth and people out
there in the world they really don't
know that true they don't know what it
is they use different slogans and
different concepts for me almost every
week trying to catch something last week
it was all chaos you see me there's no K
I said no chaos I'm the one telling
everybody to be calm there's no chaos at
the White House we have unbelievable
professionals it's really I mean I think
I came up with the term I hope I came up
with the term but it is fake news it's
more than fakeness it's corruptness they
write stories without calling anybody
they write a story today I had a couple
of stories where they never call me ever
that I know of at least nobody tells me
they'll write a story about me without
even asking my opinion on something it's
totally fake I've never seen I mean
there is a story in the Wall Street
Journal today about you know about how
we've done we've done a phenomenal job
on this
the governor's dream is even gavin
newsom who you know I'm usually fighting
with over the fires and I think you
should do a different kind of a job at
the in the forests and lots of things
we've we argue a lot but Gavin Newsom
has been very very generous generous
Andrew Cuomo has been really very
generous I mean they're saying we're
doing a great job and everybody's saying
but then you read this faint phony story
in the Wall Street Journal or with the
Washington Post is going wild lately I
don't know what happened to them I guess
something happened like we don't call
them back or whatever but the Washington
Post these are very dishonest media
sources they're very dishonest and you
know what someday hopefully in five
years I won't be here and that'll be
fine I will have done I think a great
job because I don't think anyone's done
as much in three-and-a-half years as
I've done I don't think and the
administration this administration is
done a great job but the press is very
dishonest well I think they do I mean I
mean they are siding with they are
siding with China they are doing things
that they shouldn't be doing deciding
with many others China is the least of
it so why why they're doing this you'll
have to ask them but if we had an honest
media in this country our country would
be an even greater place so ladies and
gentlemen thank you very much we are
very excited about we are very excited
about in specifically what we talked
about with the chloroquine I think the I
think it could be something really
incredible it could totally depress the
times that we had mentioned wait excuse
me excuse me it could totally depressed
any time that we're talking about if it
works there are a lot of reasons that I
have to believe again dr. Han is the
expert but a lot of reasons that I would
have to think that it could have a very
positive effect or a positive effect
maybe not very but maybe maybe positive
I think it's to me very very exciting
and the beauty is I think I can say this
Steve the beauty is that these drugs
have been out there so the really danger
part of the drugs especially chloroquine
it's been out there for years so we know
it's something that can be taken safely
so it's very important
the president has asked us to expedite
this and what I want to assure you
because of the questions that were asked
but we want to make sure that this is
done well and right for the American
people the president is right with an
off-the-shelf drug we do have a lot of
information about the side effects of
the drug so that really helps in terms
of expediting but but I want to show you
that we're working as quickly as we can
I don't want to speculate about a
timeline at this point with respect to
vaccines that's in phase one trial as I
mentioned we're expecting that to
proceed moving forward and we're working
with a number of different other
companies about vaccine development was
fast-tracked
is it possible phase 2 and phase 3 can
be fast-tracked that we might see a
vaccine before that year you get you
said it could potentially be you this is
a terrific question and we are really
trying hard at FDA to partner with great
industry great academic partners to do
exactly that
no promises can be made but one thing
that we're doing is really working hard
to fast-track as much as possible and
they are
have other times to meet will be meeting
hopefully not for very long I mean I
would like to see this get cleared up
and we think we've to me this was a very
important conference because I really
think there's great potential here and a
lot of people are going to be trying it
soon like literally very soon literally
in a matter of days if not sooner in
some cases it's already being
experimented with and there's been some
very good results we'll see what happens
but if if we can be even partially right
maybe we'll be fully right but even
partially right on it this whole subject
becomes a much more pleasant subject so
thank you all and we'll we're going over
to FEMA now so I don't know who's going
but we're going to FEMA we're going to
be discussing with the governors and
lots of other people you know well I
think that's enough